[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning as
california struggles with a crush of
pandemic related debt
we're hearing from people who say
they've been victimized by frosters
and can't access money when they need it
most state legislators have demanded
answers from bank of america which
supplies the debit cards
that hold unemployment funds for
millions of californians
now many people question whether the
bank is really investigating their fraud
claims
our consumer investigative correspondent
aaron warner has been following
this story anna what have you what have
you found because i know you've been
investigating
thank you gail yeah and you know after
our first story we asked viewers to
email us about their cases and we found
a disturbing pattern
people who say they are fraud victims
who say the bank
left them in need without the money
they're entitled to
creating beautiful tasty dishes is
something georgia moran
usually is paid to do as a private chef
but during the pandemic
i lost three bar mitzvahs two weddings
so that part of my business is gone so
in june she applied for california
unemployment benefits which the state
pays through bank of america debit
cards like this one but moran says when
she reviewed her account
she saw someone had taken out over 300
dollars
two days in a row so she called the bank
on december 17th
when i called to make the claim the
fraud claim they froze my account
that day bank of america told her it
would investigate but then she got this
letter
saying her claim had been rejected the
date on the letter
december 17th they closed your
investigation
on
not
not available she says her account is
still frozen
with the bank now holding over 8
thousand dollars still in her account
i have the feeling like it's not going
to come back to me
john and julie luna say they too lost
money when someone went to various
southern california atms and drained
john's unemployment account
stealing over five thousand dollars five
days in a row
of thousand a thousand dollar
transactions i was out
driving somewhere and she called me
hysteria i couldn't understand her
she was uh screaming she was crying and
the only words i could understand
was bank and money john says bank of
america told him
too that it would investigate then sent
him a form letter dated just two days
later
rejecting his claim they're basically
saying that
we believe you committed the fraud yes
that is exactly how
we felt that we were being treated we
asked people to contact
us and found a pattern the bank sending
the same letters to people who say they
were the victims of fraud
telling them their investigations were
closed which meant
if they didn't call the bank back to
reopen their case
they would never see the money they say
was taken from them
i think clearly they're not
investigating david chu is a california
state assembly member
that they get a letter 24 hours later
when clearly no investigation has been
made where the bank
tells them you know what nothing has
happened here or this is your fault
it would not surprise me if there was a
violation of the law here but bank of
america told us in a statement it
follows all federal requirements in
reviewing every claim
and covering losses it said the ongoing
fraud is unprecedented
and that criminals who applied for state
benefits frequently withdraw funds off
their cards
and then falsely claim these
transactions were unauthorized
and in a hearing last month bank
officials assured california legislators
when it comes to legitimate card holders
we investigate and we refund or credit
the funds back to the account
that's what we do but this former bank
regulator
questions that it does not sound like
bank of america is making a good faith
effort to investigate these claims
salisbury university accounting
professor david p
weber used to work as special counsel
for enforcement
for the federal office of the controller
of the currency
the agency that primarily enforces
banking regulations in your view
is bank of america breaking the rules
here when it comes to these regulations
yes it's not reasonable and i don't
think it's good faith
for example he told us what he thinks
bank of america
should do when there's alleged fraud at
atms
they could pull that camera footage and
they could see whether the consumer that
you spoke to
is the person who swiped the card there
is no way
in a span of less than 24 hours that
they are able to look at that camera
footage
both chew and weber believe federal
regulators should now look
at bank of america's practices it's
unconscionable
the fraudster is getting to keep the
money
and then bank of america is getting to
keep its money
and the only person who's suffering are
the american families that should have
had the money
to help protect their family in the
middle of the panda
well the occ and consumer financial
protection bureau the regulators would
not comment
bank of america says it has paid out
millions of dollars in claims
and the people who get those letters can
call back in
to get their cases reopened they also
told us they're working on a list of
people that we
provided to them the lunas for example
say their money has been refunded
georgia moran is still waiting tony her
account's still frozen
yeah well it shouldn't take anna werner
from cbs looking into it to get the
money back to people
but it does help anna thank you very
much